William Goldman's legendary book
adventures in the screen trade warn
writers never to write scripts with
things so imaginative they could never
be practically filmed today's visual
effects masters prove there is nothing
that can't be brought to life this
year's nominees made us believe in
everything from mind-bending space
voyages to dancing baby Groot here are
the nominees for achievement and visual
effects Captain America the Winter
Soldier danda Lou Russell Earl Bryan
grill and Dan sudoc dawn of the Planet
of the Apes
Joel Atari dan lemon Daniel Barrett and
Eric wind West guardians of the galaxy
Stephane Sarah T Nicolas a toddy
Jonathan Faulkner and Paul corbelled
interstellar Paul Franklin
Andrew Lockley Ian Hunter and Scott
Fisher x-men Days of Future past
Richard stammers Lou pakora Tim Crosby
and Cameron wallflower
and the Oscar goes to interstellar Paul
Franklin Andrew Lockley and hunter and
Scott
well thank you very much the Academy for
this thank you to Chris Nolan and Emma
Thomas for taking us on amazing voyage
across space and time thank you to
Paramount and Warner Brothers to our
producers Kevin Elam and and podlaski to
the teams at double- New Deal studios
and also amazing special effects teams
to all our friends and family who
sustain and support us through all of
this to my amazing wife and fantastic
children for putting up with so much and
and thank you to one of the smartest
people on earth
professor Kip Thorne of Caltech and all
the Explorers of science who show us the
universe in all its amazing and
terrifying beauty and one of these
apparently is good for a free drink so
we're going to go and test that out back
there thank you coastal princess ER